welcome to this video this is round six
coverage of the dashing off memorial
tournament currently hadn't shown kia
azerbaijan round six let's get going i'm
doing things slightly different
differently today i decided to do my
usual way of sorting the games is kind
of I don't know giving away sometimes
how there is all this or how the games
went so I'm going to stick to
alphabetical order now so i'm starting
with atoms with white against maxima
sheila graph and let's get going c4 okay
slide surprised by Adams it's not that
he never plays c4 or most other than
efore but it's still relatively rare and
we have g6 quite a long pause here for
mvl okay at G 337 and we had a
symmetrical English on the board couple
of moves later yeah this is a very solid
way of playing for both sides actually
one thing to take note of is that wide
with this early g3 and 93 like this he
really focuses on looking at the d5
square controlling that very much but
he's not really preparing to push d4
opening in the center which is hmm if
you want the only way to really open up
the position quickly and get some kind
of give some kind of bite too wide set
of its this is all very very solid play
93 here black has a big choice you can
choose 'if I've e6 d6 Knight f6 and so
on and a move that is rare but not bad
as night h6 here played by rochella
graph yeah enemies now played H for this
is one of the replies that are one of
the things popular against nine th six
it looks a bit strange yeah to push the
H porn here but it's one of the few ways
to give the gift especially some kind of
bite if why does instead
assouline black is putting its night
down and by increasing the control over
deform makes it very difficult for y to
ever get anything going in the center a
choice at least a little bit creative
but still it cannot really in danger
black very much as usual in this in this
type of English opening where white is
not managing before there is some
situation where black is very solid d6d
3 yeah white also had h5 but it's not
leading to that much ultimately the
official g4 is a possible reply yet d3
shipped reform in 27 so black is
developing if you want his Queen ER and
preparing in the case of a counseling
and Bishop h3 castle of course castles
looks a bit a bit strange maybe because
well why chest plate h4 early on and
didn't really do much with it um but
it's certainly possible Adams played
differently did not um go for castles
yet you played rugby one emphasizing
queenside play why not it's a one of the
few things that white can try you're
already gives here that I'm quite
skeptical about why it's opening chances
here and yeah that's really the case I
don't think white gets anywhere if he
avoids in general this kind of stuff is
just nothing for white due to various
setups ePHI v6 they all they all
equalize but well it's playable of
course getting to some kind of a slowish
position but it's not there's not much
hope for getting any pressure on black
yeah well rupee one going for a before
base plan this is some what white
hassium yeah interesting moment now I'm
what what did maxime Rashida graph do
now one problem is a little bit that
this night is it's it's funny it's a
funny place for the snide and in some
situations this can be a problem let's
say um he would play
castles him he would have played castles
one idea is this Queen see one that
attacks this night if you now think
about this night f5 that's all of a
sudden night h2 and this Bishop is
running into some trouble right that's
quite awkward so castles is not good so
what what I is supposed to do you can
play this first but again night h2 is a
slightly awkward reply asking this
bishop where it is going autumn Utley he
decided to play a pretty radical
solution but probably not a bad one just
went back to g8 yeah that looks very
strange but nowadays those moves are not
really well so sensational anymore if
you remember in this gentleman Wesley so
played one game where he had the knight
on c6 against vishy anand with black put
it back on dat ya and then we she played
95 and he went back to c6 so it's all
about finding good concrete solutions
for the position at hand and not about
following some kind of general principle
yeah he reroute the night to a good
square on f6 why not and while the whole
proceedings he are so slow that it
doesn't really matter that much ok 93 to
avoid some traits like captured and now
before his white has to do something and
this is accomplished with before opening
up the queenside yeah Brook PA to cover
the pawn castles and I think around here
not exactly here but close to that yeah
we had even more trades it looks very
equal ish e6 Bishop f3 and now black
went beehive betsson that's an
interesting decision um of course it
looks like the logical move in a way to
clarify simplify the whole queenside
situation where white is having a little
bit of pressure against b7 black of
course also
at the move b6 um i'm a bit i'm not sure
i mean i think b6 might be better I'm
not they're not completely sold on b5 um
but I understand why black black would
want to play b5 it's really the kind of
movie you want to make sure that you're
not getting into some passive situation
um I mean what I'm what I think is if
what gets in like here here a4 a5 yeah
you may be faced with some slight
passivity that that you know that you're
sitting in but I don't know the thing is
b5 it's a bit tricky after that white
has creepy one and this is not easy now
for black there is pressure on the B
file and you well it's difficult to
avoid the loss of a pawn to be perfectly
honest you went a six and now III III
deformed shutting out this Bishop it's
very difficult for black here to avoid
the loss of the b5 pawn in the game we
looked at Queen a seven he gave this
pawn of immediately but it was difficult
to hold ya White has ideas to to
strengthen his his grip there and
there's also a for ultimately a ba de
sunder pressure I'm not sure I think it
looks it looks a little bit tricky for
black in this position I mean if you see
what happens in the game yeah he
directly gave up the porner but wyd
spaceship of course had to spend a
couple of moves there we had this
position I think that black here has
very very good chances to draw but it
still feels that this is a bit more than
white um yeah deserve to get if you want
I think well if you go back here this
looks like very equal ish yeah why
should white get an extra porn position
so maybe b5 wasn't the most precise way
to claim and giving up this porn but I
still think that what winning chances
are very slim the problem is simply that
we have opposite colored bishops on the
board and
many end games will be just very very
dry in this situation rook see one looks
very normal but deform is a very awkward
reply it's important that i could not
just take the open file down ruki one
and rook c8 and we see some in some way
we already see blacks compensation hear
what he has is see file control C 3 is
very weak and this Bishop gets rebooted
to evade I think the the upcoming moves
are very young very logical and they
look very very normal yeah black got
this activity in and it's really
difficult here for white to make any
headway without trading stuff because
black is so active his pieces hell are
very very active you don't get the apron
rolling at all and you have to offer
trades and in some way in the in the
game we we had now after some
maneuvering we had this trade and now
here we see how active blacks position
is it's difficult to avoid the Queen
trade even if you're also if you think
about ideas like that that are in the
position yeah auntie em this is really
just the draw there's nothing that you
can do the problem is that if white
pushes a form then we see that black is
controlling those possible entry squares
for the white king and the King side is
completely closed and symmetrical we see
that in the game if white tries to avoid
that and let's say um what did Blaine
Blaine played f5 let's just say why
tries to invade on the queenside you
know I'm just putting some some moves on
the board yeah like black is just
staying not doing anything and whenever
white is coming over they are trying to
invade and support the a porn then
bishop you one is hitting and while all
this is going to drop so white hands no
way forward team they play the build
bitten this is the different scenario
with a form
wide open this check when did they agree
to draw now here you yeah it's really
just the total draw there's nothing
nothing to be to be done here for for
either side you offer black especially
not with the pot in town but why it
simply has no winning opportunity
whenever he goes over here like will
take the d4 pawn and sacrifice the
bishop at the end for the airport it's
just just completely dead yeah not a
super excited game this this opening is
some is something that this kind of this
kind of opening here something that can
always be played by the white player for
trying to play a slowish game but it's
very often you don't get anywhere like
here and I still surprised that wide got
this extra point position in the first
place it didn't really feel necessary
okay second game by alphabetical order
is um Geary Geary with white against
unless Carlton let's get going d4 and we
have my e 6 was the first move I did not
did not know that actually I was I was
only seeing that seeing their opening
that resulted so Magnus awesome offering
a French defense but Geary didn't go for
it interesting did he think about that
actually no he didn't he just played
this instantly uh huh interesting okay
well the French is not part of carlin's
regular repertoire but gear is um is
switching between a foreign d4 so it's
not completely unreasonable to think
that he could could go a form okay so we
got a real goes in route goes in defense
of the Queens gambit Bishop to g5 one of
the two main lines cd5 is the other one
got h6 and this trade yeah this line is
some really safe choice yeah it's
something that
i also have a bit of experience in from
the black side and i think when i
studied that it wasn't the 90s it's a
bit been a while back then it looked
very solid to me and it still seemed
solid to that day let's see a couple of
more movie three castles roxy one takes
takes c5 yeah this sermon has been seen
a bit in recent top level games the most
relevant for our game here being the
game Yvonne shook with white against
Magnus Carlsen so the world champion had
that on the board just a couple of month
ago in the Tata Steel event in January
back then Yvonne Shull played castles
ctx Knight takes bishop t7 Queen here 96
96 Bishop takes well you get the drop
everything was traded down to a quick
draw so we already see that this is a
fairly solid very solid sounds get sound
a line but not too exciting especially
we have to say that from White's point
of view this is not very exciting here
for example instead of dt xe5 which is a
relatively rare move white also can just
I can know play what is more interesting
I think it's you can you can try this
this and now you can go nighty for this
is I think one way to do it or in
general going for sea takes default
position not a position with night XD
form yeah well give recaptured and was
part of his preparation as we see
Carlton went Knight to d7 yeah it's some
more interesting trying to take that
oops take that with the night yeah
Bishop takes let's say castles and this
Bishop is always sitting in this idea
which leads to further time loss and so
97 and now c6 that was why it's idea
yeah interesting situation now Black now
has three moves basically and at first
it looks like he
just has to take when did this is a move
right as we he could have taken um what
you don't like about this so much is
that the ponyo is a bit look something
isolated white has a slightly better
structure and yeah let's say castles and
this is completely equal I'm not sure
about this it's certainly playable for
black but um I understand what Carl
zindgi mean this is probably the move I
would have chosen as well you went 95
that's it's a bit more interesting the
idea is that if you look at this well
widen what captured and this looks
fairly fairly forced yeah this is
hanging also so took their queen takes
and well first thing you ask what about
what about the pawn there won't be seven
can why take the pawn after Bishop takes
black has a very nice compensation for
his pawn he's attacking g2 which white
has to attend to and then I move like
rook c8 this gives black excellent
compensation for the pawn yeah Queen to
g5 isn't is an idea with a maid threat
trying to provoke more weaknesses Black
has a very active position this kind of
pawn sacrifice is actually quite quite
known from some lines in the Queens
gambit declined classical Bishop e7 um
so it's um it's a known idea um guia
didn't take he played castles and it
seems that with the look of it this was
maybe the first move that he really are
played out of his preparation well just
speculating they have it don't know
looks like it looks like it from the
time time spent here white had an
alternative to castles and I think this
is maybe one of the few critical
positions in this game queen bee three
was interesting playing directly against
the the bishop there on d6 and um yeah
there are now some interesting
interesting complications that black has
to has to choose from you can play
something quite simple like a five for
example but after a three txt
yes Teague's takes he's some stuck with
a slight disadvantage for sure you
simply have the worst pawn structure
it's not the end of the world but
certainly a position that is someone
better for wide a different possibility
was Bishop a five after queen bee three
also quite interesting after taking
Bishop takes Queen takes root piayed we
see that black is getting very active
and after this this this and bishops III
is getting some material back what wide
remains with this a pawn so this might
be okay for black and some kind of draw
our sense because of the opposite candid
bishops on but well it's not comfortable
or anything it's just a question if
black can hang on so it's clearly not a
desirable position to be in yeah I'm not
quite sure what black should do after
queen bee three it looks to me that why
it is a little bit better black in also
well you can do this you had a simple
check is completely simplistic approach
but yeah I mean white must be better the
sea porn is still weak so on it's not
completely satisfactory yeah I don't
know I don't know what you would have
played after queen bee three it it
doesn't seem seem very very obvious to
me maybe here maybe this is an idea just
just occurred to me if this is maybe an
idea it's interesting after this this
black really has huge activity and while
this this is not leading to anything
okay but why does enough does not have
to take it can also play this I did not
prepare that before the video let's just
occurred to me this idea okay the black
has has some activity here right and we
can try this for example
and try to get this back like this this
this and they have some compensation but
do you have enough not sure queen bee
three seem critical to me but it didn't
do it he cancelled and now cousin took
the porn yeah and well the difference is
that now we have Queens still on the
board which makes a huge difference
compared to the other end game type of
situations where blackhead queens traded
and then was stuck with the weeks upon
here black is totally fine yeah at all
it's all looks very very natural and
check was more trades and short order
like took and c5 and now we see that
it's completely equal right so this kind
of evaporated quickly into into
absolutely nothing yeah it Queens traded
and where we can spare the rest of the
move saying they played a couple of it
and nothing happened it's just just the
total draw um yeah as you see both sides
only spend a little bit more than 30
minutes for the whole game and it was 37
moves yeah this is all about the
situation he has to go queen bee three
to try and form for something at least
and not with them yeah they I think
they're reasonable chance is some to to
get something okay so one next game is
what is this chronic right chronic
kawana let's switch to that
is it where's my my notes here I know
it's okay so we had this yeah after
considerable thought gee 693 is already
a slight surprise because on the top
level they all play to see form
basically because there is little point
in playing 2nite f3 nobody avoids that
the budapest are over all the other
banco or whatever and see far as the
flexible move let's say but 90 or three
years well it's a bit interesting that
Cromley goes with that and he now plays
Bishop g5 in fact yeah so he has
prepared the Tauri attack against g6
against carwin awesome try to play hit
the Greenfeld okay so Bishop g7 C 30 now
the clock is corrective maybe he played
it a bit quicker that's strange the
clock times locked here a bit strange
okay I didn't look at the clock
situation beforehand but also I was kind
of funny okay well what kramnik is doing
is just playing a very healthy setup of
course you're developing his pieces and
kawana is going for d 5c five days reply
of course this kind of slow edge build
up with Bishop g5 gives black some
choice yeah he can play with d6c 5d five
and c5 various setups this is of course
a very very good one for black very
solid 1a6 that's an important little
move that black absolutely should play
it's a very common reaction to those
kind of situations where you fianchetto
and you got this push of the flank pawn
what black wants to avoid is if if he
goes Bishop d7 and and ignores whites
whites idea then a5 is a little bit
awkward yeah you don't want to take ever
this is just weakening your structure
quite a bit like night could possibly
come to take it on a five or in any case
if you lose they five point you are
settled with a pretty bad a porn so you
don't want to take but the pawn on e5 is
always a nuisance it has the twin ideas
of taking and playing a six and you have
to think about both constantly for
example if white gets in Queens way for
a six could be a threat so it's almost
automatic for for a good strategic
player here to play a six yeah come on I
took a while to do that quite
surprisingly it looks very very normal
but okay if he has to check things and
and so on but it certainly the first
move that you considered okay before now
back ramnik an interesting try playing
on the queenside Bishop e7 and now
kramnik went a five it's interesting it
closes down the Queen side this is now a
forced sequence and b5 yeah very
interesting both sides now are settled
with this bad squares this week square
so there's a possible Black Knight
coming to c 4 and the night coming to
850 to c5 yeah this is very comparable
at first but what has them has slightly
the better of it because he has the more
aggressive a porn the a5 porn is kind of
nailing down a six as a weakness that a
knight will attack from c5 we can fast
forward a little bit and see that they
both were aiming for this squared a f-1
see five white ultimately got a night in
there okay this is a stern interesting
moment g4 was played by Crom neck not
the most obvious move but interesting he
wants to get this Bishop to g3 and then
put it behind the pawn chain and then
trying to advance on the kingside
interesting move but I wanted to show
this situation ya both night nights are
now in the on those weak spots and while
whites night is always attacking a six
the same cannot be said for blacks 99
and c4 is certainly not badly placed but
it's not attacking anything in
particular so I think white is probably
slightly slightly for for choice iam
let them go forward a little bit up to a
critical situation mmm let's see 16 and
this is here yeah as I said the first
impression is that what should be a
little bit better because of the of the
a porn but there is a there is a problem
here if you think your betters wide um
and from what I heard on Rhett on on
today on Twitter it was um he was very
optimistic in in the in the post post
game press conference that white is much
better him um well if you believe that
and play the game you have to you have
to justify your belief somehow and have
to find some some active plan some way
forward here for white and this is not
easy at all if you I mean I looked a
little bit well I can show you what
kramnik plate and this is not to be
honest it's not very good but the thing
is that what are you doing if you really
think you're better and it there are
things pointing to that yeah with day
six pawn being under fire um you have to
back it up with some kind of positive
plan for one and it's really difficult
what Kramnik tried was f3 for breaking
through in the center um as we see you
this is not this is not going to work
but um well what are you doing I'm
really not sure I mean maybe it's just
the case where this does look nice with
c5 lighting and ce4 night but it
ultimately still does not lead to
anything in particular that's really
possible there are those cases where you
think okay isn't this something but well
black is also quite solid it's not that
well a six is the only thing that counts
as a weakness and the rukon a7 is doing
a pretty good defensive job and you did
it secures the part and in situations
where this night has to move on as kind
of unstable or whatever the
look my to swing over the right moment
we see some of that later in the game
yeah so well chronixx plan as I said is
not going to end very well f3 is not
particularly bad but the the
continuation after that seems to
backfire quite enormously went 9 f 4
sorry given night f4 and now 97 that's
an interesting way to play kiwanis we
rooting the knight to c6 where it looks
at before white also has a big part on
before yeah this is something that
should not be forgotten the real problem
for wine is coming here if kramnik is
now let's say if you're if you want to
call it like that backing down and
playing some some passive or passive
some some less ambitious move let's say
yeah like Queen you won or something
like that or just I'm staying with now
I'm not doing much then probably that
this not it's not so terrible but well
what is facing is he played f3 which
weakened III and if Black gets an e5
under favourable circumstance this is a
weakness the move the whole idea f3 was
too pushy for and this is maybe a case
of who said a has to say B he went he
for now but it seems that this is to put
it frankly just not working after 96
which was kind of clear I mean the case
of what else yeah I'm black is attacking
those two two pawns what really doesn't
have any anything like a satisfactory
reply well I did not watch that
mentioned press conference would be
interesting to learn what Kramnik had
planned against it because it cannot be
the game continuation you see very
quickly that that white is on the ropes
it's a it's a bit it's a bit weird yeah
he took on d5 him and here can wanna
just just grab this um
I really don't know what what chrome
like was Kramnik had planned yet would
be interesting to learn very often it's
not that I mean Kramnik is a strategic
genius and chess righties say seeing
that he's full of weaknesses now and and
it's bad unless he has some kind of some
kind of concrete concrete play but there
is simply nothing concrete that that
white can can try it on I really don't
know what is what his idea was it must
have been some some technical thing he
he took on e6 d6 maybe this could be an
idea maybe he was planning this and was
was banking on on a on a discovery by
this night that that's possible maybe
what happens after 96 for example this
is some a line that my my engine is
giving that is a weird we had type of
line what is this doing actually a 5 is
hanging and still the night on g6 or
saying maybe he was maybe he was
planning this that's very much possible
yeah that's very much possible and if
you look at this now what is wyd doing
him if he moves to the night back like
is able to do this and a5 is hanging
still not totally clear to me hmm it's
not a clear position maybe I mean this
looks at least far more dangerous than
then what he did he took on his six
maybe d6 was was a stronger stronger
tribe it's at least a pretty forcing a
black has to take this this Queen da
that's quite interesting white also has
this move
hmm yeah I think and this is probably
still preferable to what you did after D
takes is six I mean black looks better
and in those lines but after D takes is
six it looks really grim Knight takes
rook takes and hereafter f 66 karana was
much better but he in fact he had a
better move that the computers pointing
out going to f6 this is even stronger
yeah it attacks the night here two times
and well it has to move there is
absolutely no alternative after a night
move I mean if white takes community
eggs as a disaster and the queen is
queen is hanging and this is also
hanging so why lose this big material
yeah White has to move this and then
after room shakes black it's just in a
fantastic shape yeah he's got great
pieces much much huge activity and look
at this uncoordinated bunch of bunch of
white pieces that was even stronger than
F cakes but black retains a clear
advantage also yeah it's simply due to
the fact that black is is better better
positioned with his bishops they are
more active white as many weaknesses you
know a 5d form this is all a bit much
yeah here corona had anticipated that on
Bishop h3 this is what chrome Nick plate
he has a very strong reply he now
sacrificed the exchange and played 'if
I've that's very strong based on the
fact that this rook is unprotected white
cannot capture on e5 he had to move the
bishop and then efore was the gather
opened the floodgates we had the bishop
on a eight is so great white has nowhere
nowhere a big alternative had to go here
and now he went Bishop g5 yeah why not
the capture check there's this annoying
check and after King moves d5 yeah that
is to be avoided he went this went with
this first
simply based on the consideration that
white can never take as Luke takes
setting up for a deadly discovery a two
I would ever square you did you have to
have to go to just terrible and with the
check your on the King white cannot take
so he's just delaying the capture one
move Bishop b5 takes Queen f2 and the
Queen 85 yeah why does what is falling
apart is king position is just too bad
look if eight and we still have a couple
of points on the queenside ash never
forget those but it's not even necessary
either the black black pieces just just
invade him with decisive effect nor I
continued by the longest one I didn't
even look at the final couple of moves
yes sir check check oh why he paid us on
for for quite a bit yeah this is made
now takes check and checkmate checkmate
yeah chrome nakum certainly was a bit
frustrated them um yeah it's a bit
understandable I mean it's not that he
spoiled something brilliant or so but
it's a case where when white white was
trying to create something trying to get
something active going with this f3 a
default plan and it completely backfired
after 96 I think he probably had some
kind of miscalculation that here that he
M that he yeah that he had when he when
he went for this idea and and this was
this was the problem he certainly saw
that this is leading to to strategic
problems but he was relying on some kind
of line that did not work out ok the
next game to check is mmm is it mommy
Dolph yes should be mamedov her Mammadov
Arnold can you confuse their with the
alphabet mummy dog Anna okay one year
for my mum adolphus usual move and V she
goes for c6 the Kirk on defense yeah
this is part of his repertoire
not a very regular opening from him um I
was a bit surprised to see that but
maybe it is due to the fact that um
Mammadov is not playing the advanced
variation of the caro-kann he has played
especially in recent years month um some
offbeat lines relatively offbeat lines
like Knight f3 or he went also 492 which
is a funny move yeah so he played some
kind of offbeat lines and maybe witchy
was speculating to get one of those but
mummy dog just went on d 45 and 93 very
normal and takes takes a 97 yeah and um
the mama dog strategy in this tournament
seems to be yeah being solid first and
it's it's it sounds maybe bit cynical
but let's say he seems to be okay if he
draws eight games and lose this one he
doesn't really try to let's say come out
with guns blazing win two games lu7 or
something like that yeah which is I mean
it's understandable yeah you want to get
your foot on solid ground when you are
entering tournament of that that's
strength for the first time so is he
wants to play solid chance Bishop c4 and
I'd have six and captures this is a
signal that okay I want to be solid
today um 95 is the move here to try for
something like II six Queenie 296 this
can actually lead to fairly interesting
and sharp positions where um like your
neck here t6 back you see five yeah
right sometimes even castles long and
try something here with G for just one
line I mean white also Castle short
quite a bit but this is still
interesting but you did not go for that
as mentioned yeah he took and played c3
this is a super solid line where white
is delaying the night f3 move for one
moment the idea is that whenever you go
Knight f3 there's always Bishop g4
around the corner giving black and easy
development of course if you
do this here Bishop g4 it's not a good
idea to this tactic but in general yeah
you have to be yeah have to be conscious
of Bishop g4 here black can play some
other move Bishop f5 or some other prep
move to avoid the immediate check there
on f7 yeah c3 Quincy seven this is a way
to move to wait for 9393 Bishop g4 yeah
you might ask why not Bishop f7 now I
have a jack check okay this is the point
yeah this is why i put the Queen on c7
h3 and black just took this is the the
best solution if you try to keep your
bishop you're always subject of h 4g for
business trying to push the bishop on
the corner and taking us is just simpler
but this is also a structure which is
notoriously George yeah if we look at
this yeah white is just developing and
centralizing and the best that black can
do is basically just sit sit on the
position and be content with with an
equal equal position near bishop the
sixth Ranger and to trade stuff yeah
it's really not much to comment comment
on they they traded traded pieces here
yeah of course not to the capture right
this is not a good idea but it's not
necessary at all yeah it is very
difficult in this kind of position um to
make any headway White has no great plan
he's quite active mommy see that looks
on the afar but what exactly are you are
you planning to do if black is not
falling to let's say Bishop takes c6
sacrifice um it's very difficult you can
try to put your King side pawns in
motion but that also beacon is quite a
bit
and black really can just sit I mean you
can do like I can try that be five
before c5 but it's not not so easy to
get in yeah in the game King g7 was
played Queen g3 yeah this is not working
anymore as the king is helping to
protect Queen g3 and well they they put
out a couple of mumbles not going to be
and this was the repetition ya have to
be honest air that wasn't a very
exciting game um and this is well a
little bit due to the fact that white
decided to play it very safe and he can
also play more interestingly against the
CARICOM of course I think we she was
speculating a little bit with c6 that
maybe mamedov was going for one of his
one of his side lines that he recently
had played and get a more interesting
interesting fight um it's it's it's um
it's a matter of few if they play is
black against someone who's playing
efore and its content with a draw it's
difficult and well Arnaud is in a good
position in this tournament but he
certainly does not want to lose or risk
losing so he has to try to find
something or play something that has
some some implemented some ideas behind
it that there you maybe have some
chances to do to go for a win but he
doesn't want to risk much and he was
offering a little bit like okay I go to
go with the calc on are you playing one
of your interesting lines ok no you
don't do you play some interesting main
line no you don't ok you don't want
anything okay then it's a draw so it's
some those kind of games oh it's a bit
disappointing to watch but you you
understand the rationale you don't want
to do anything crazy and what what is it
that wish you could have done c 5 g six
maybe yeah Sicilian mommy don't plays
Bishop b5 check it's also rock solid
it's difficult if you play against
someone who just once a draw in this
term is a decent player I mean they're
more than decent you know but from
vicious point of view is certainly the
better player
Mammadov but it's not that he's playing
some kind of some kind of bump from the
street okay let's get going Wesley so
against Shia mamedyarov this is the
final game of this round of the in this
presentation we have west leg going
deform now in place on opening moves and
again the Slav this is what mamedyarov
had played earlier in the event and this
is a heavily a theoretical game um I'm
not going to talk so much about all the
moves leading to it 95 is one of two
main lines and the other one is III III
is arguably the more yeah let's say the
simpler way to play 95 allows and offer
some some very sharp complications 97
let's see for Quincy seven and now g3
and d5 this is a line that was out of
fashion for a very very long time until
the year about 2,000 when murasa which
was playing this quite often with
excellent results and one of the reasons
for his excellent results is the move g5
yeah that's a really really modern move
yeah you go g5 out of the blue it was a
bit shocking at the time to see that
nowadays is just the main line of the
Slav um yeah it looks a bit crazy but
what black is doing he fights against
this pin yeah white obviously cannot
take the pawn this is hanging then so he
has two choices he can take on e5 or you
can play Knight III counter-attacking
this Bishop there nowadays 93 is
probably the main move I did was played
she takes a four and nine TX and 5 now
this this was played also in them in the
very first game with that on high level
Kasparov of all people with white
against murasa which long castles
and Queen c295 X takes a 5 yeah the UM
this is a very peculiar position Black
has good pieces there see five and five
nights yeah they are very nicely
positioned on the dark squares in
general black has a good grip on the
dark squares but White's night is very
strong an f5 and in general black skin
positioned or also sometimes tends to be
shaky yet it's not a very very classical
paw information here this is this kind
of thing so it's a it's very it's very
sharp but also very well explored this
has been played countless of times age
five Jack trades t1 queen here Queen
aged a bishop 83 yeah threatening on the
diagonal so King 822 yeah eyeing the
critical squares there we should be
seven yeah Bishop e7 this is the this is
a one of the most have a look down um
mamedyarov I mean he's playing this line
now and he plays Bishop e7 after 30
moves yeah at 30 minutes of thinking and
this is a bit strange to be perfectly
honest because I know it sounds weird
but the theory of this line is starting
here it's not ending here this is all
known to people play that regularly and
what I did I picked up the book about
this opening which is the classic the
classical sloth but Boris of rock
released last year and well this is of
course in the book and what of what does
I've rock say about Bishop e7 he says
this is a bad move and and black should
play h4 with excellent equalizing
chances okay I'm not going to analyze
this now yeah there's there are plenty
of ideas takes bishop h6 for example but
it's not really feasible to make it
three reticle over you know about this
opening but this is really really well
known bishop
7 it's in the book it's just bad and why
is it bad because of what Wesley is
playing Queen III Queen g6 rock default
this is technically a novelty it has
never been played in a game at least in
my huge database but in a Brooks book
that's exactly this given rock before
with a large advantage for white so this
is what we call an opening disaster on
that level from Omidyar off you just
play the line that is known to be
terrible quite strange to be honest
because it's I know it sounds weird
because it's moved 20 or something but
this is the beginning of this line it's
just just like that it just it's just
strange that she that he falls into this
kind of bad situation okay what can you
say when 96 and 94 that's one of the
problems white with rook deform has dual
ideas he sometimes can play 924 but you
also uses rook on the fourth-ranked to
control and a crucial square 96 as
mentioned is watching what you played
here for example age for the idea that
we have seen before is simply answered
by the capture and here we see one point
here of the brook you're winning upon
them so h4 is not possible I'm not quite
sure if you can improve here for black I
mean what are you playing a queen g5
getting just push back simply it's
simply not a good position 96-94 Andrew
kadhi 7 this is what was played and we
come to the critical position right now
Normandy are off wed looked the eighth
attacking the rook and in this situation
now westleigh with white eos less so i
went to clean to d3 relatively quickly
it seems that here the key moment is to
UM the key moment is here this is there
this is a correct sentence i say i guess
here there is the key moment to to
improve on White's play
but it's not not trivial of course the
computer is giving the trade their shade
and it has some some very concrete
points let's start with Bishop d8 and if
the bishop takes white has this move
which is attacking f7 and it's very
awkward how do you protect that pawn
it's not just the pawn it's also this
kind of this this fork of on Queen and
Bishop so you just cannot move the F
porn let's say yeah there's also a queen
bee three by the way that's also very
very problematic made on b7 Wow andy
sixx is hanging yeah this is this is a
huge problem here black to continue has
to play 95 and Bishop g2 94 night f7
this is a red computer move typical
computer stuff that is says that this is
almost impossible to see for a human
here at the end of the end of this line
is seized white being a pawn up a five
is hanging and he protects the the night
there very strange very strange line
white is better this was this was 11
line after you create the other was 98
and here white what was the line cheeks
and pigs and now Queen d2 were thinking
if I have that right yeah Queen d2
attacking a five oops checking a five
and it's difficult to protect that yeah
if you think about this you can go here
but why this is able to get to capture
because sorry d 8 is hanging yeah it's
it simply it's simply not very good but
what can you say it's not a very good
position for for black the capture on
the AIDS seems to be a be the best reply
after queen bee three it is a fast draw
really it is just like that ticks ticks
Queen takes it from ya in 97 that was
why it's idea with
to this there's always the idea of our
perpetual and there is no way out of
that he took their on f7 check but here
we see the problem there is Knight f3
coming and it's absolutely no way out of
this out of this perpetual night a 391
those kind of series of checks it's
impossible to prevent check your him
check ultimately decided to give the
perpetual himself so a draw in this game
and a very lucky one for Mammadyarov
when playing a clearly worst opening
here with this Bishop e7 which is known
to Theory very much it's something that
you usually cannot afford on that level
but it turned out to be not an easily
refutation I mean West I played the
right moves I with rook t4 but um then
at the adhere this particular moment to
take on the aid and figure out all those
somewhat weird complications is
definitely um definitely tricky and
that's nothing that probably is in
anybody some preparation from the white
from the white side okay I hope you
enjoyed this coverage of round six I'll
be back with coverage of round seven of
course um maybe on the same day maybe as
it is some with this round on the on the
following day I'll see what I what I can
do with my my other things on my
schedule ok I hope you enjoyed it thanks
for watching